barrett-jackson the world's greatest
collector car auction is back
in las vegas earlier today i drop by the
convention center for a preview
hey guys this is unbelievable on so many
levels first off we are in the brand new
convention center it is open and second
this is car heaven there jackson auction
is back in town
craig jackson how does it feel to be
back in las vegas it's awesome we have
been here since october of 19.
last time we were we're in mandalay bay
we're excited to be in the new
convention
center we've been waiting for this for a
long time and
for those that haven't seen it this is
your opportunity because anyone watching
by tickets right
my tickets online here at the door yup
go to our website
barretthyfenjackson.com or you can buy
them at the door
so we're open to the public the
restrictions are off
and we have 700 cars selling at no
reserve let's start showing you some of
the cars why don't you come over here
craig and lance get a shot of this
because these are some of the star cars
that are on display
what's the one we're looking at right
now so this is a 94 rolls corniche this
was a gift from roy to
or from siegfried to roy for his 50th
birthday
a ton of pictures you see the seat
covers the
cats uh used to ride in it all the time
and a lot of pictures of them going down
the strip with the caps in it
and this is one that people can bid on
this is the product right yep we're
selling this for the estate
unfortunately
you know they're both at our 19 auction
and there
roy bought this for siegfried and then
he wrapped it in the chrome wrap
and uh unfortunately we lost siegfried
also so we're selling both
siegfried and roy's personal car now
somebody like this this kind of chrome
wrap on it someone's driving here in las
vegas is it reflective with the sun
a little bit yeah but it's i like it my
bugatti's wrapped like that
it's gorgeous it's gorgeous and of
course the icon we got several
this is frank sinatra's blue eyes
maserati ghibli this was frank's own car
frank's own car wow okay so now this
week
same thing people come down take some
photos with it or if you want to come
down here you can bid on this car
you can buy this is las vegas history
right here las vegas history
and then we lead into and the third car
isn't here so we're selling three cars
for mr las vegas he actually did
the open to our show today wayne newton
so these two roses come from wayne and
we have a one-off
custom rolls-royce or not rolls-royce
mercedes-benz
that he will also be selling and he'll
be here saturday selling his car
so he's also a fixture he's helped us
also
we're mandalay bay after the shooting
help raise money for the first
responders we sold steve davis and
shelby for a million dollars
you know barrett jackson's been here for
you know back from 08.
so we were here during the the recession
we were here right after the shooting
and we're here coming back right after
covet so this is amazing and you you
give back to las vegas there's some
charity cars that are up for grabs this
weekend there's
a raiders uh broncos yes oh it's
incredible yes and that goes to that
grant to get for autism i believe
charity so you guys do great things for
las vegas
the las vegas convention center is open
you can come down here and check it out
you can bid on cars you can watch the
auction absolutely craig thank you so
much for bringing the auction back to
las vegas thank you
come visit us come out here guys you can
stop by barrett-jackson's auto auction
it's starting happening today until this
sunday june 19th
and they have something for everyone in
the family to enjoy you can get your
tickets online
at barrettjackson.com and i'll be
showing you more barrett-jackson
tomorrow and of course today is our
last day for the giveaway so make sure
to stay tuned for your cue to call
we're giving away two tickets later on
in the show las vegas now we'll